that's the question before the American
people and only you can decide what you
want what you want this country to be
around the same time of the historic
debate between John F Kennedy and
Richard Nixon the man who would become
the 35th President of the United States
created these watercolors of New York
Sheepshead Bay painted and signed by JFK
now for just the second time they're
going up for auction as part of a huge
collection of Kennedy memorabilia at
Boston's our our auction house so a lot
of people don't know that kennedy
painted but he painted he drew and he
had you know he had our artistic sense
to him a well-known doodler JFK also
painted as a way to relax even finding
time to take out his brushes during the
heated 1960 presidential race we see
sailboats all through these important
documents like during the Cuban Missile
Crisis on it he's drawn boats Kennedy
wasn't the only president skilled in the
art of painting president and former
civil war General Ulysses Grant studied
painting in West Point and produced
about 10 works during his years there
another general and president dwight d
eisenhower
took up the hobby at age 58 at the
urging of winston churchill some of his
works including this portrait of
churchill now hang in embassies and
museums some of Jimmy Carter's paintings
have sold for more than $250,000 but
it's former President George W Bush who
may have taken the title of artist the
most seriously he's created a portfolio
shown in galleries and even on The
Tonight Show but organizers hope these
kennedy creations entice a big-time
buyer because of Camelot and because of
Jackie and because of the youthfulness
and the hopefulness of the Kennedy
administration and how that was cut
short
Kennedy collectibles have more value
it's amazing when you think about all
these people were known for their
leadership and yet they have that
there's something
I think it's this distress and it's just
how hard these jobs are and I did you
can get lost in the pain then to be able
while you paint well that's what I
absolutely know very talented stuff it
goes through Thursday Thursday
you